here's the problem with only dating in
your church okay it's actually not
really a problem for men because there's
more men in the church
but
oh no sorry more women more women more
women sorry sorry there's but for women
they would always say in my church like
back home that like you could only date
a guy in the church but i'm like
there's three girls for every one guy
that's conservative
what yeah yeah so then all these girls i
think just end up alone because they're
waiting for a guy in the church that's
never going to come
so in my opinion the church
kind of keeps women single and i don't
think i think god is conducive to like
families like he wants families to start
yes and i don't know i think there's
something about like biblical
institutions that have been running men
out of them the last like 50 years what
do you mean like like why are all these
men they're men used to be really
involved in the church yes and but
they're not anymore so something about
these institutions are running men out
talk to me come on
no they can't hear you come to mike i'm
gonna take my i have to take my mic
if you want see what i'm saying okay i'm
gonna repeat
there's someone on our couch that didn't
want to be in it
in europe yes okay one is because men
might be seen as i don't think i can say
this one youtube
they say
you can't say it on youtube it flags it
okay yeah involved with the young
children
yeah
yeah and then the second is the rise of
independent women
in the church
honestly what i'm thinking about when we
talk about church institutions is like
one thing person this is just a side
note
i think a lot of people
need to
focus more
on their relationship with god yes than
a church because i had
growing up i had a mother who put all
her time in the church this and that
this and that
and then there will be like shady things
happening in the church is going on
so why
but at the end of the day
basically it's all about your
relationship with god
so all the other stuff don't really
matter so when we put all our time
in uh doing this and that for the pastor
i don't think i think it's a waste of
time not a waste of time but like you
can put your efforts in better things
well every institution is going to get
corrupted at some point like there's no
there's not a perfect institution
but but i think but i think that you got
to ask yourself the question does that
mean we just do away with them and don't
use them at all no no i'm not yeah i'm
not saying that but
know
know where your focus should be
know what your time should go into yes
basically in my in my opinion like
there's certain things that the church
do
that you should
feed into prayer helping out each other
i remember i was at prep school
in north carolina i was good i was in i
don't even need the prep school but i
was at a prep school and every week
the pastor the pastor's out here getting
um he said oh yeah
offerings for this offering so that he's
like yeah the prep school here
uh everyone would do an offer for the
floor we never saw the floor got done up
nothing oh my god and i was putting i
was putting in 20 us dollars i didn't
have no money at a time but the floors
were bad and the pro the the pastor gave
me a a sermon and it hit me i was like i
said move me i'm like yeah i'm up i'm
gonna tap my car for this 20. it moved
me and then after everyone's like yo
what are you doing don't do it i'm like
why you like bro this guy does this
every year he's never fixed the floor
jeez and he has like
six cars in his garage um so those type
of things when i say right when i say
focus on your relationship with god and
not yeah and not believing
yeah yeah
that's yeah those are the points that i
mean you know yeah come out not to
interrupt you but that man ultimately
has an answer to god for that he has to
answer to god for manipulating god's
people or the sheep or or the the or the
bride of the church
for his own personal benefit he has to
answer god for that and that and and
this and that's why i agree with you
you have i was saying the same i write a
lot i love to write that's one of my uh
greatest gifts
creativity is my number one number two
of the right
and
one of the things that i write um
sometimes daily is that you have that
form your own personal relationship with
god because pastors and certain people
can manipulate who you are
and what they want